to meet you you're Caroline's tonight
and tomorrow yes sir and dude fit you
like a million bucks
thank you are you dressed just for me
yeah yeah yeah what else are you doing
what else this is it this is it oh and
Zoe I'm doing sway okay
but no I dress I thought you know I hold
you guys in high regard
no silly I've been fans with you guys
from you know Australia you know Jim you
know the story you know and you know me
even in Singapore Malaysia listen you
guys so this is a huge throw for me poor
Malaysia that we will you doing gigs or
what were you just your life yeah this
would be my life in Singapore and I
moved to Australia for law school law
school in Australia's undergrad so I
moved there as a 19 year old and then
just when I was finishing law school I
started doing comedy
oh yeah Australia's a lot you want to do
oh man whatever I could get a job in
honestly I couldn't get a job that's why
I did comedy couldn't get high it's
great grill we didn't have good grades
but if I if I great terrible if I if I
did do a lot probably do some corporate
stuff you know okay you did graduate I
graduated I passed the bar in Australia
and I took the BAI New York because I
thought that would be the way the move
here and I failed it so you failed the
bar filter by tougher here yeah the body
is tougher yeah the body you're not a
strong test taker are you already
breaking stereotypes yeah not very good
that tests and testing I came in 2011
that's the first time I came to New York
well I let me to take the BAI exam and I
didn't I didn't get to meet you I was
already doing comedy for two years and a
huge fan of New York stand-ups American
stand-ups and so I remember after I did
the after I did the bar I didn't know I
failed immediately I didn't know that I
did the bar feeling pretty good when I
went to go see you know why I really
came to New York for with stand-up
comedy so then I went to the cellar and
I went down I I was there like an idiot
I was at the door going here you can't
come in and the cell itself sold out
every single night and the the bouncers
I know so though and I'm like oh you
know man Todd Barry's on right
and I I came from Malaysia I do you
might understand the hallway for like
five minutes I'll see you talk berries
now and I'll get out and if for some
reason the bouncer was like yeah okay
let me do it yeah and now now I know
better that they never let that happen
right yeah we fired yeah and I heard
that I was trying to figure out ways
bounce so that was and I think he's the
one who passed away she may be shacked
again right a little shack Hughes guy
who looked like she keel really nice
dude
I forget what he died of he's big guy
yeah but they call it was a baby shack
or a little shack I forget what the name
then you know Bethany I never that's
only time I met him I told my I came
back to it I got passed as a seller I
was like telling all the other bounces
that story all the security and they
were like they were all like we would
never [ __ ] do that it must have been
the shack so and yeah so what
how did what were your first comedy
influences like how did you how did you
even know cuz you said right start do a
comedy kiss your grades sucked right how
did you know that that was a thing well
I mean well I well well the commands
when I was a kid I was growing up in New
Hampshire my parents actually came to
America as in the late 30s to go to
Community College from where some from
Malaysia okay so you know born and
raised in unity
yeah and they went to college so late
they had two kids by the time I went to
college that's how late it was I was
like four years old this was when they
were in their 30s not in the 1930s so
this was late 80s Early 90s sure
Manchester New Hampshire and then we
will watch man saygus is what it's known
as Vegas and Seinfeld was on and so he
would do the stand-up at the end of the
show not every episode and be like man
that's awesome I won't try that
something and then it took just a
Seinfeld doing it on the show and I know
people can just stand up and tell Josh
yeah yeah and I'm talking to my dad now
and he because he's actually visiting
New York he very rare visit from
Singapore he's actually visiting these
two weeks and we were talking about
comedy in America and he was like yeah I
saw Seinfeld on the Carson show and I'm
like what you mean like a YouTube video
he's like no I remember I was watching
Johnny Carson and it's time for went on
and then I saw him and and he was like
who's this guy and then my dad was like
oh this guy's really funny and then he
was like I should try watch him live
sometime and that you know just seeing
the lame
and process of how people watch stand up
and go yeah he's how they connect with
Stan right yeah yeah he was well known
before he did his show though Joe he
wasn't a star but he's pretty he done a
bunch of Johnny Carson show national
headliner like people knew who Jerry
Seinfeld was but then you've got a show
and you know it always is interesting
because comedy is such a world like into
and of itself does its own sometimes a
bubble no I know greatly but there's
like there's always that one sort of
thing that's the breakthrough you kind
of dip your foot in and then you find
yourself in that world but right for
obviously for your whole family of a
Seinfeld yeah yeah so the Seinfeld and
uh so watching that was like oh that's
something I could try but then I didn't
do it for like 25 20 years so what the
hell you know so to me 20 years the
jumbo stage and it was in Australia when
they did it so what's the comedy scene
like in Australia it's it's it's good
that you know Jim came down a couple
times I wonder why wait I did Melbourne
and Sydney and yeah I liked it I liked
Sydney I did better and then then
Melbourne Melbourne was fine but Sydney
I had a better draw what about for the
locals like yeah where were you yeah
well I was a I was a Melbourne guy okay
but towards the end of my time in
Australia I was basically touring around
the whole country so it just became like
one
you know continuous City I guess but I
was going Melbourne Sydney a lot but I
started you know I was it lived in
Melbourne for 10 years I started comedy
in Melbourne and they they have their
own scene it's I they they have their
own comedy festival you know it's a it's
a yearly thing that goes for like a
month
so people do do you know you do shows
there and it's you do like one-hour
shows that you don't do like 10 minutes
everyone does like one out for better or
for worse it's like Edinboro I've never
been there but I've heard it yeah that's
correct yeah right it's like a
month-long festival yeah at some point
becomes like a comedy marathon honestly
like you're just punishing yourself and
everyone there are you dying
yeah like three times yeah and you have
to they say sometimes you have small
crowd sometimes a big you know the whole
time yeah yeah you said for a month and
then you do so Edinboro is like the
largest life Performing Arts Festival on
the planet and it's a combination of
three different festivals as the it
started with the Edinburgh Festival
which was all the traditional arts like
ballet and symphony orchestra
and all that kind of you know kind of
stuffy classical stuff which is still
awesome look at me wrong I'm just saying
that that was the mindset and then in
response to that they created Edinburgh
Fringe which was the fringe stuff like
magic and comedy and cabaret and they
had that and then that became his own
beast from a fringe thing to its own you
know corporate thing and then in
response to that they had the Edinboro
free Fringe because they felt the fringe
was becoming too corporate so there's a
free Fringe and then so you have
literally like 5,000 live shows
happening at the same time in Edinburgh
and you're how you've got performers and
you know audience members and somehow it
works every year you think it's gonna
collapse in itself yeah [ __ ] I like I
see Americans come to that and I mean I
it's it's alien to me - I'm not from
that cut you know that I'm not from the
UK and it's Americans like will be then
like what is going on here like how this
is sustainable no one's making money by
the way it's all if I go you'll be lucky
to not lose money in Edinburgh but
there's something you have to pay for
the rooms yourself and then yeah and
then and hopefully make Miami tickets
you yeah it depends on your deal like I
you know if you're bigger act you can
get a good deal where the best deal I
got in Edinburgh was if you lose money
don't worry about it
but if you make money won't take half of
it that was they take a piece of your
money yeah yeah yeah and they'll you
know the thing is you you have to pay
for your venue and your marketing and
that can add up the use of doing it's
like an old school record contract yeah
yeah and I guess the goal is to get if
you you know have a good enough show
that guess enough critical response that
you can tour the show around the UK
that's kind of the battle it's about the
exposure yeah yeah and you know we think
of exposure now as something that's
people used to you know trick people
into doing free work yes you know but
back in those days you as you you guys
would know like there was no internet
that was only way you could right
exposure so it was actually legit and
you will get you will get onto the BBC
you know get onto a panel show least
okay this guy's on the panel are they
struggling now that people don't aren't
so hungry for the exposure because
there's things YouTube Twitter you on
facebook have 6 million people so yeah a
little bit but then I can't but no but
then that that that as true as that is
and that is true that's the case now
when you people still go there people
comics still go and perform and there's
something both you know dumb and pure
about going there and it's not about the
money and it's not even about doing a
good show it's about just doing it like
it's almost like you put yourself
through
yes fit comedy all right you can do it
prove that you can do it and have the
experience yeah yeah and obviously some
people go there and have better runs and
other people actually make money and
actually get you know no but she's goal
of us is there so you were born where I
was born Malaysia then you go to New
Hampshire yeah well then how long do you
spend in new handles in New Hampshire
for four years and then went back to
Singapore okay so then you're in
Singapore mistress yeah I actually he's
kidding you really do yeah it was a
great time everyone's like I I was too
young to know Manchester sucks
yeah well that was awesome and I still
awesome in fact the I I got to when I
move when I join the daily show there
was a Manchester political debate or
something so we got to go back to
Manchester New Hampshire and I went to
go see my I took video of it I went to
go see my childhood apartment is still
there and I went to go see the park I
used to run in I used to because like
when you're four years old
the world is like four places of course
it was like school home the park and
then the library and then made like a
grocery store and one restaurant and
everything is huge yeah and everything
is huge and it was this [ __ ] awesome
you could I remember we could like you
could drive home and like not lock your
car door you could run upstairs and you
know it was like yeah oh no I thought
was great and right you're like whoa we
got a park here [ __ ] best yeah I have
a great time see there you go you're in
Singapore and you're like okay let's
jump in what is I'm Malaysia like is
that like a real conservative religious
place yeah it's a majority Muslim
country so it leans on the conservative
side by it's officially secular so it's
not it's not like ruled by Islamic law
anything it's a secular country but it's
majority Muslim do you go there at all
or no yeah yeah my parents are they yeah
I don't show them I you know I'm from
johor bahru in Malaysia so I hang out in
Jobar oh and I'm back to whenever I can
hang on single single point in Malaysia
well specifically johor bahru it's like
Jersey and New York it's like just
amazing you can just cross
in fact when I was a kid I used to lived
in Jobar and then I would take the bus
to Singapore to go to school every
morning and like five million and yeah
you cross countries to go to school so
at what point you find yourself an
Australian I love how in America is like
it's too many things just be Asian
right yeah Australia and Malaysia
seems like there's hints of an
Australian accent until just now oh yeah
yeah it's there I've never noticed it I
guess kids you know I just always known
you your voice on stuff on like the
daily show and stuff you can hear like
words that I'm like yeah thanks a lot so
when do you end up in Australia oh I
went to it's always in Singapore for ten
years and then I went to Australia when
I was eighteen to go to law school right
okay yeah and that's when you find
comedy and then yeah and then you move
to New York two years ago yeah what kind
of a culture shock you I guess you you
were in Australia stay coming from
Malaysia and Singapore well you know
Singapore is a law-and-order place yeah
no spitting gum and yeah it's not a
crime it's to spit gum in the street yes
should be here too ah you're not kidding
rude people walking up and down these
sidewalks Sam I know you're kidding but
yeah they're just that was that what
that kid got caned your since a boy's
name my forgettable face Michael go
change and then Clinton stepped in yes
douchebag that was a huge scandal
massive stone yeah I think he graffiti
yeah yeah
cars or something spray-painting cars he
got caned and then Bill Clinton got his
caning reduced by like 1 or something it
wasn't didn't hit by only a few times
you sure four four times but that [ __ ]
is like that's a that was negotiated
that's like it breaks skin it does yeah
that stuff is not yeah you don't want to
do people still get caned yeah it's
amazing as an adult being like oh no I
don't want to get a special yeah it's
also weird there works you know I mean I
get caned in also see balls don't get
hit
that's a good question I think I'm not
sure actually I think you have to put
someone whole there's a doctor around to
make sure you don't get it unless unless
that's part of the thing it's like yeah
you're gonna arrest you yeah it is it's
your ass getting kicked I don't want to
kill you sometimes you wouldn't die from
getting cane in the balls good
yeah really thank you good well strike
could kill you well right yes bosses pay
to dominate wrist and ankle and she
couldn't go so she whipped his balls and
he drop dead so the whole thing about
being can't I want to see that for a
second how do they protect your
testicles when they can you don't do
they know that's a great question so
it's a big thing right and they really
wind up and [ __ ] belt you with us
yeah I don't know I like I've never seen
it done in person I've seen canings in
my secondary school in Singapore people
got caned but with like clothes on right
I wasn't government came here wasn't
government canings I Stefano moment
caning is the MBA of caning right
government caning right it would be like
detention is not jail school caning is
not going I want to see video there
video of caning I think they probably do
I forgot serious we can do whatever we
want we want me talking about this is a
show in prison can know what First
Amendment you know it's different man
you guys take First Amendment for
granted you know other countries you
can't does not you don't know what it is
until you don't have it you know people
complain but First Amendment to be able
to say whatever you want right we're
just happy we can say [ __ ] on the radio
we just do it cool not showing the
caning I think I've seen footage of it
but they use a big it's not a small cane
it's not a little thing no no it's not
and also I haven't done research into
this but there's like there's different
I don't know how much is marketing but
sometimes they show like a huge one
something to do like a short one
sometimes they show the guy being like
restrained on to this wooden it looks
like a guillotine but it's for your but
but it might be so they can just scare
you in a night yeah yeah I don't know
what the official procedure is anymore
oh man we can't watch this you don't
want to watch it you can't watch this
man they tie and they're always wearing
something over his body but this isn't a
single pool yeah yeah giant crowd
they're cheering they're loving it dude
they are thrilled there's
sold out there seven days yeah just like
all my ass cheeks
Ronnie che if I'm charged gonna be at
Caroline's tonight in tomorrow and sell
as much as caning sold out hopefully the
same results Ronnie canes hecklers do
not try anything how did you get the
Daily Show today were they looking for
people had they seen you yeah I
confirmed this is Trevor after the fact
at a time I didn't know I did a show
with Trevor at just the last in Montreal
and into 2013 and yeah 2013 and I you
know I guess I had a good set and we met
very briefly we didn't exchange numbers
or anything we didn't meet again for two
years and then two years later in 2015
when he got the show I got an email
asking to audition for it and I suspect
it was him but I wasn't you know you
have a knowing that asked him afterwards
and he was yeah he said you know very
you know huge fan undoubtedly
wanted to you know like some Asian
people represent a little bit sure on TV
which you know I I I'm not I'll take it
thank you yeah I hope so and you know he
really empowered he really had my back
and really empowered me to kind of do
comedy in America and I was gonna move
here without the Daily Show I was gonna
move here anyway and now I laugh at the
naivety of moving to New York with no
gig with no gig and trying to do call me
from scratch because that is a brutal
scene just a guy you guys will come up
and be like how do I get on to the
cellar you guys to recommend you and
then she'll watch your take like that's
how it is yeah and I'm not gonna
recommend I don't know right you know
because that's probably what they're
looking for right I recommend a lot of
people sure but you have to know them
you have to actually like there's to be
a real recommendation not just I feel
bad for the eventual rep you know as
your rep as well yeah I'm not gonna
represent I'm gonna lie to her tonight
know someone if I don't but it's fun to
watch people did you see all these guys
outside like they're on MacDougal Street
and they're kind of Hawking for other
clubs hey come on down they're like you
know they're barking yeah and that's
really paying your dues man guys that
stand out there in the [ __ ] cold and
the rain
always root for those guys I always root
for those guys too but some of those
guys aren't even comic some of them are
yeah yeah I'm right will you guys never
do it for station you just do you know I
don't know how much money the game pay
but it couldn't be that much but one
thing I love about New York comedy is
just the history of it you know the
history of Ed and what's cool is Jim has
been a part of so much of that history
you know and you wouldn't know by if but
yeah cuz he doesn't talk about a lot but
I mean unless you why did I mean he
hasn't he certainly hasn't moved on to
other things just saying that you're
such a big part of New York comedy
history Travis was talking about as well
I know it's just saying that you haven't
you really haven't moved on to bigger
and better things
just hanging out like an ambassador
Jim's an elder statesman but to be the
wall fly yeah you've you've met an
interactive of everybody in most people
yes just in your comic American comedy
it's interesting yeah like you probably
you probably met Garry Shandling Garry
Shandling I only met once and Sarah
Silverman introduced him to me in front
of the Comedy Cellar right but I love
channeling growing up I wish I would
have known him better yeah yeah most
guys when you were standing up most guys
know each other on some like it's not
surprising when you meet a stand if you
meet an actor and they're like hey
Ronnie write that like [ __ ] they know me
right but if I'm usually not charged
yeah a comic I wouldn't be right so was
the was the Jesse Watters thing that's
the first big thing that broke for you
right I guess yeah so was that weird
that like your response because you I
don't know if you remember Jim when
Jesse Watters did this you know Jesse
Watters from Fox News he did this on the
street thing where he went to Chinatown
and he was talking about whatever he was
talking about but the real joke was just
like look you know Asian people can't
speak well and it was like I think that
even people who were Jesse Watters fans
had to look at that going like they
weren't ready to jump on and be like
funny guy they were kind of going like
oh really
right I'm not sure right it's
interesting I mean as comics you know
would like everything's fair game so you
know I don't try to be funny and then we
just had a response and I was I was very
lucky to be in a position to respond
yeah and the fact that that was that
much backlash I don't think I you know I
take it as
that no one was with the joke and they
wanted a response so I'm you know I was
happy to be in a position to provide
that was almost almost perfectly in
position because there's no other Asian
on a new satire website to make fun of
sure you know so did you feel it was
there pressure on you after you realized
how many people were paying attention to
what you said in the sense that like oh
I didn't realize I was gonna be the
representative no you know in the moment
again like it happened so fast so the
day before the new story dropped and
then the next day we went out to film it
and that's one cool thing about The
Daily Show it's kind of like the New
England Patriots you're like on to the
next it doesn't write so you're not even
thinking about your place in the
national conversation you're just trying
to do a good piece which is I think how
it should be there's too much stuff
going on you're doing a show every night
yeah and that's a good about day show
you do a good piece you you know you pat
yourself on the back for about five
seconds and okay well we go do again
tomorrow it's gonna hang if you have a
bad show you go alright well and do
again tomorrow you know it's just on to
the next and what was cool is that I
went when we did that piece I went down
to Chinatown to get the opinions of
people in Chinatown which was the whole
point to show that people in Chinatown
have political opinions um and I was
worried that you know you encounter a
lot of apathy or you know just no one
would care about it men complete
opposite soon as I got a car I was like
are you here to talk about that thing
yesterday alright coming and then they
lined up on the way to come in yeah and
and and give that so I didn't even have
to do anything but everyone the street
was [ __ ] on this guy more than more
than I was to be on I was just like
translating some of these people were
like and then we we asked them to speak
in you know Mandarin or Cantonese or
whatever they're speaking because the
point being that you can have you can
have opinions on American you can speak
two and a half what's what's the the
other what's the other full one and
what's the half I speak Chinese Mandarin
Chinese and I speak candies how hard is
Mandarin Chinese like gene Simmons is
trying to learn it because he just likes
to speak Farley John John Cena learned
it it seems impossible yeah Chinese is
difficult because there is no and I I'm
speaking someone who look I look Chinese
when I was eight years old so I'm not
native right Chinese Pig I'm my first
language is English so I had to learn
Chinese from scratch okay and his
difficult because there's no link
between the written and the spoken in
Chinese you can't sound it out you have
to just know the words
you can't sound out like in English you
can sound out the words in Chinese you
just gotta know the symbol if you don't
know it you don't know it there's no you
can't walk it out you I think that
memory thing is the reason why I think
Chinese people like study better because
that's Bishop learning that two traps
just reminded me yeah oh you can't you
can't just kind of make it out you can't
half know it and make up the rent you
can't fake it
you can't fake the funk you have to know
that [ __ ] different like I know it's
just a voice inflection sometimes will
mean something what's an example of
something that one word that means a
couple of things I mean I mean word wise
it's not so much the wood is the
different inflection so you can go
scissors and all those different means
yeah there's a difference so su means
means yes and it means die so you got it
yeah
so what do you want to say yes die yeah
sounds like a but I mean like me and you
in trouble do that for again the son of
the ears to to pick that [ __ ] up
I guess cuz I don't I don't yeah Chinese
but I could tell the difference to them
I can tell no difference but like I'm
telling it's the same as any other
language it's the same as any foreign
language and in foreign language so if
you I know it sounds like alien to you
guys right now but it you know it would
be like if someone spoke Arabic to me or
Spanish I wouldn't get it either no I
know familiarize yourself with it and
enter the world but each symbol is a
word is that what it is yeah each would
is a symbol as a symbol for it yeah and
then you have to just memorize it on the
bright side there's no there's no tense
so there's no past tense present tense
do of that you know you don't have to
conjugate yeah that's awesome grandma's
a little easier than conjugating foreign
language class oh my god I [ __ ] up
I have no grasp before I took two years
of French I know none of it it's
probably of a grasp on the English come
on cut it out
kind of company I'm sorry I didn't mean
it yeah no I I speak really well as a
well-spoken man will do that's right
that's 100% correct yeah and also in a
sentence you would never go scissors you
know you never say that that's just for
yeah would so it sounds confusing there
but it's like I would never go there was
no situation where you go scissors you
can read it as well I speak I can read
one order you're gonna say yes die
oh no no there'll be a different you you
you need more words to say that
grammatically in Chinese you bi uh so
the thing things that's like yes please
die or you need you would not say yes
that yeah you wouldn't say yes doctrine
sued no you wouldn't say that you
wouldn't just want to say that wouldn't
happen yeah I wouldn't have how do you
say yes please die sir the things I
guess I just don't grasp it but you when
you read does it go right to left or
left to right around traditionally goes
up and down and but the modern ways we
just go like English right just go right
to live and each symbol is stupid but
like individual letters yeah this like
each alright like Chinese like what does
that mean like with that top left one
how long it take to write that's fine
that means the first the first one the
left says English and then the same in
England and second ones hand honey I
think someone and III think it means uh
English and in Chinese that's basically
saying what the top - yeah that's
English
yeah there's [ __ ] three dots it looks
like the come emoji hopefully no one's
checking this on YouTube if I [ __ ] that
up people be like how did your how did
your parents feel about you doing comedy
instead of law yeah I didn't tell them
did they know that you were no good at
school well they still it was our lawyer
son on television
then I didn't tell him I just did it
like tip for Asian kids just do it don't
even have the discussion just do it and
I was lucky because I was living in a
different country to them so it was
harder for him to kind of keep tabs
right and my excuse was I was still
technically still studying like I was
still I finished my law school and I
started comedy and then I was like in
the process of passing the bar which is
it can be six months it could be a
two-year process I just took two years
to do it I could've done in six months
and you got a movie coming out to write
with constants work oh yeah our crazy
situations yeah absolutely crush on
constant she's she's not fresh off the
boat yeah is that the and movies coming
out August 12 the trailers dropping for
the movie on Monday so check it out it
looks really dope I play I play the main
character's cousin Eddie Chang who was a
huge dick and which is true the
character I guess and then yeah we're
just just balling in Asia basically yeah
there's all layers to the movie I mean
that's
there's the Asian so it's the story of a
asian-american girl who falls in love
with a Singaporean guy and then they he
brings her back to Singapore to meet his
parents and so immediately you have this
kind of you know asian-american
rediscovering Asia layer
you've got the romantic comedy layer
you've got the and it turns out his
family's super-rich sabalan layer so
that's the ball in Li and then you know
she comes from a more modest family so
you have that kind of social class
dynamic and also you know the family
dynamic his mom obviously is judging her
for you know her place in society um and
it's a it's interesting because it
showcases Singapore as actual character
in the movie like a Woody Allen film the
way New York is a movie because usually
when Hollywood shows Asia it's like
where James Bond like [ __ ] a girl and
then lose the next day you know it's
like just literally a place for him to
have a one-night stand but now this is
like the whole movie in Asia yeah right
so it's it's cool to actually showcase
Asia for where
we shot it on location in Singapore
Malaysia which was fun that's amazing
it's a kind of mind-blowing - you did
like all this is kind of all happening
at once in the sense that like you got
this movie you got The Daily Show you
got you've been you haven't been in New
York Jim and Sam
Jim and Sam and Jim yeah Jim and Sam a
big I mean I guess I are you just doing
your Daily Show strategy where it's just
like on to the next thing yeah I just
keep on to the next right otherwise you
you if you start I don't know I feel
like when you stop believing your own PR
is when they take you away from you I
think right you guys just I believe not
always believe mine I've been told I'm
garbage I'll never take that away
they'll never take that away from me
scrape the bottom of the barrel and get
me out yeah you guys were great I mean
um also I Jim I I always wanted to ask
you that I don't know how personal this
is but I've like you lost a lot of
weight yes
when I first off all of you to madness
look at my co-host and lose my appetite
[Laughter]
eating getting fitter eating right
that's all it was it really was just
just working out and not eating shitty
yeah I got tired of it yeah I'll look in
a certain way yeah in fat
I'm telling you anger is the best way to
lose weight best motivation yeah it's
just look at because that's why I lost
like 10 kilos as well he's just selling
coke I lost 10 keys yeah a little
different if you say that when you work
for Pablo yeah
yeah I lost it and same thing it was as
I looked at look I was I was touring
stand-up full-time leading a very
undisciplined lifestyle you know
sleeping whatever you want
eating whenever you want whatever you
want waking up whenever you want and
then but that sounds so great
it does but if you're a normal
functioning human being after a while
you just go man this sucks
my life I got a together yeah yeah you
just get angry at yourself and then you
lose 10 kilos or cream pounds right is
that easy
I see how do you are you all the metric
systems like our dear do you know I
can't I can't do Fahrenheit I don't know
what the hell is going on Fahrenheit fan
time I'm always it's 80 I don't know
what that means is that and I have to
look everyone someone tells me the
weather I'm always okay and I look at my
phone I do the same thing Celsius thinks
though it's 10 degrees out that just
sounds so terrible actually I've been
looking into this a little bit
Fahrenheit really is very stupid the
idea things like freezing is 32 degrees
that doesn't make any safer enough that
is an odd place to finish dumb thing
like is it freezing in fairness lots of
arbitrary numbers in America as well
like but what's the quarterback rating
it's like two sixteen for some reason
that's the Mac like it's just arbitrary
number yeah yeah 32 is what's boiling is
boiling a hundred degrees boiling isn't
even a hundred fulfilling height
that's why doesn't makes it what's was
boiling for Fahrenheit I don't know can
we look that like we should know that
okay why should water whoa this is why
we should know because in Celsius zero
means freezing hundred means boiling
right and then that makes sense that
makes sense it's pretty easy
yeah we don't know what boiling is in
Fahrenheit its 212
and also there's no so zero to 100 it
means that you one degree increase so
you know you can judge like if 100 is
boiling water and zero is freezing right
50s in between their 40s in maybe like
four Fahrenheit you don't know what's
now at 32 and 200 what's the hottest
that will ever get for uh Celsius
Celsius I don't know if it's like 15
what is 50 equal to what 50 50 degrees
Celsius 50 degree Celsius Hot 100 and
122 degrees Fahrenheit okay so usually
doesn't get up to 50 okay yeah 42 40 42
years ago
14:40 summer hot summer day of 42 but
that also sounds lame
oh it's a nice warm 40 degrees summer
day well I don't know I don't either is
terrible like it's like 90 degrees like
it sounds wintry how many times have we
said that yeah we don't like wintry
sounding temperature Ronnie is gonna be
by like caroline's tonight and tomorrow
how do you pronounce your last name as a
change okay right because there's an IE
in it that's why I'm asking it it's
Ronnie ch i en g.com and at twitter and
there's two shows tonight I'm guessing
two shows tomorrow yeah and the daily
show what is your schedule like are you
shooting stuff every day or do you write
off for a few days and then shoot yeah
well in the office every day and it
really depends on what's happening on
the day whether you're on that night but
we're always kind of prepping for the
future you know but it really depends on
what's what the story is that morning
sorry said will you come up with the
concept I wanna go out and do a field
piece on this yeah yeah well come on I
mean whether it gets approved is another
matter I proved but but I you know I'll
pitch for myself you know stuff I feel
passionately about I'll pitch for it
other people in the show pitch for it I
don't know what SNL is like but but the
the daily show is very collegiate
environment I bring up Sno because I
don't know if it's you know it as I hear
I said I was a little bit more cutthroat
but but um did you know you you have an
hour and a half a week and stuff is
getting cut and blah blah it's only a
certain number thing where it's like you
said on The Daily Show there's another
show tomorrow there's another show
tomorrow I guess so yeah yeah but they
really have a really good like a
friendly environment Israel everyone
they're like if you're a piece of [ __ ]
at a Daily Show you just stick out like
a sore thumb unless everybody's talking
[ __ ] about you behind your back maybe
they maybe I'm the you know they're very
[ __ ] a friendly but you can tell like
because I think it comes from Jon
Stewart because I'm a him a few times
and and you know this is the way he
built the show was he was also very
down-to-earth guy he doesn't make a big
deal of you know so no he doesn't he's
not sure we do he's just rehash about
the work yeah that that has been
reflected in everyone he hires you know
yeah reflect that kind that was passed
down yeah you can tell it's so obvious
when you go in the building it's very
yeah I get I mean that's the bet if the
goal is just for everybody to do a good
show
yeah let's do this one host - and I
think the idea of that is when you have
one host everybody is kind of knows that
that host is the star of the show
no one is everyone's not competing for
the same amount of airtime
okay sure the SML is a much more of
everybody the stars
yeah and establish star of The Daily
Show the stars change from sketch to
sketch whereas with John or Trevor even
when you're on you're still the head of
the show the face of the show maybe
that's why it's a little less
competitive and more like let's all
maybe yeah but it's it's a real
supportive environment as well it's like
people pitch for me other correspondents
pitch for me which might be you can
argue it's against their interests
because you're about themselves the
picture me I picture other people you
know there's no like I don't know
there's never any like if someone we
always want to find the best person to
do that job it's never like I won't do
that have you ever had a person come in
like clearly just about themselves and
then you had to get rid of him or
whatever I had the Daily Show not know
since I've been there Wow yes I'd be I'd
picture you but I would do a poor job
Ronnie wants to go out and do this thing
where this wants to speak about how
Asian people speak English in response
if you guys want to do that could be
interesting because he should be doing
it you know interesting did you get
another perspective what if a white guy
went in and did it what if somebody like
yes just pitching yourself you picture
yourself with his bit right great idea I
mean you know some people think a white
guy to do this right yeah then you go to
Ronnie these guys they don't know what
they're doing they want me to do it I
don't want to do it I told them I don't
want to do it yeah but they it's there
the boss I guess I go speak Chinese in a
vet I haven't I would do your bit I
don't I would pitch you so shitty just
because I wouldn't want them to go
through Ronny most do this thing where
he talks about Asian people like I can't
believe what a bad idea is right
you never say it's a bad I never what
are they gonna say you made a face and
then they're going oh that's a great
idea and you're good yeah I mean I know
that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah Celsius in Chinese that's what he
wants some very weird I don't know it's
kind of one so weird one I like it I
love it I think that's probably a better
a better way to be is everybody
supporting you but course it is you get
four nights so what do they do Monday
through Thursday there were five Monday
to Thursday shows and then Friday at
half day okay so it's the best job in
comedy it's the best um calm you can
tour yeah you can at night the show
finish taping at 7:00 7:30 you can go do
spots around New York and you're not
always getting what time to get to the
office in the morning I get there about
9:30 so you're and you're not always
gonna be in the office are you there
every day I'm there every day unless I'm
out shooting yeah unless I'm not
shooting them what's better than a nice
late call time for shooting oh man
doing stand-up yeah no but isn't it
great when you get a late call time like
when you know you got to get up and
10:30 you know [ __ ] he's not lazy like
you so lazy Sam I'm [ __ ] not helping
people all night chasing down buses that
you think might be stolen that was a
waste of time when I was cruising around
looking at ladies of the evening and I
happen to notice that one time one time
Jim was driving around looking for
numbers I'm a penny saw a public bus
that said what what did the liteup say I
believe this bus is stolen but what did
the light that you saw in it I think it
said stolen bus or Hall help yeah and
Jim followed a public bus around well on
foot no in his car you just drove around
with it for a considerable amount of
time Wow nine-one-one yeah called 9-1-1
on it it wasn't so on it was so stolen
they actually caught that guy doing
something else years later I believe so
people followed up with it I don't think
that that's true it is absolutely true
then why was there never a story about a
stolen bus it's not that biggest story
it's a huge story somebody stole a book
time what time would date with you
evening I remember like like late night
always nighttime all right here wasn't a
stolen bus what's a stole it would make
news if somebody stole a bus Ronny you'd
be interested if somebody stole the bike
well you guys are big on reddit yeah
yeah they love multiculturalism that's
right it's bigger staying there like
inclusion god dammit
dude aye aye aye aye sir to god this is
I first my first piece on The Daily Show
first time I was ever on The Daily Show
I was so excited you know and I thought
it went well and I went on I made a
mistake of going to The Daily Show
subreddit and I never I have never been
back to the Daily Show subreddit since
then since since that first show ever
true they probably shaped like I own I'm
not just saying this to be cool I
genuinely have no I've managed to not go
back to the Daily Show subreddit I don't
know if that's trashing him but that
person was like oh these guys are not
from me - okay but the thing is you
can't like criticism if you think you
did something like if you were really
confident comfortable in something and
the criticism doesn't make you doubt it
then [ __ ] the criticism but if the
criticism makes you go [ __ ] is that a
valid point
sometimes it's available it's hard to do
it's hard to distinguish but I think
when you have something like reddit yeah
where it's like this is just a place
where they're [ __ ] on you yeah and
you're like oh wait I thought this was
the place that likes me when there's no
other side you're just reading the
criticism right I here's my favorite
reason is that the people criticizing
you need to be qualified to criticize
that's it you gotta be unqualified
criticism is [ __ ] pointless because
you know you don't get it you don't know
what's going on you don't get a context
if man if you know even we're talking
about comedy or stand-up like there is
no way that if you've been doing
stand-up at a high enough level you know
what you did wrong even if you did
something wrong you know what was good
what wasn't good you know I don't see
any benefit of listening to unqualified
cream I don't know if I agree with it
I'll tell you why because it depends on
how they're criticizing but if people if
someone who's never done stand-up is
going the way he structures a joke or
comes up with a joke is incorrect and
you're right then [ __ ] them they don't
know how to come up with a joke but if
I'm an entertainer and I do a radio show
and people like your radio show suck
that [ __ ] is not funny like I have to
kind of accept that because I never if
people say your radio show is great I've
never said hey you're not qualified to
make that judgment I've long said thanks
great point sure well I felt like you're
really funny I always go thanks gladly
but sure I mean obviously I prefer the
positive stuff yes yes right but don't
you don't you feel like at some point
you know what was
what wasn't good and even things we sure
don't like you can still stand by and go
yeah I know why you didn't like that but
I also know why we had to do that yeah
good it doesn't mean out back off what I
did shows they didn't like it but the
criticism is not always sometimes it
just annoys me because I don't like it
reading their country I mean that a lot
of times it really is just it Tremont's
being country I don't like it yeah